blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
let's just get right into things today
because there is so much to cover uh
one of the things i mentioned in my
monday segment about the current
israeli-palestinian flare-up
is that not only does hamas benefit from
what's going on
because they justify their existence by
being on the receiving end
of israeli rockets but benjamin
netanyahu justifies
his position as prime minister as mr
security
when there are at this point i believe
it's 3 500 hamas rockets
that have been shot in the direction of
israel and
i even mentioned benjamin netanyahu
likely realizes that unless something
changes his days as prime minister are
numbered unable to form a government
recently
he was recently interviewed on cbs face
the nation by john dickerson
and dickerson to his credit went right
at this idea
and said essentially are you killing
people to try to stay in power that's
the crux
of it let's look at the exchange let me
get before you neither arab skilling is
wrong
or jews killing arabs or arabs killing
jews let me ask i want you to respond to
one other thing before we go which is
your domestic challenges you are under
investigation for bribery fraud breach
of trust
you've also had some difficulty four
failed attempts to put together a
government in the last 23 months
this leads to the criticism that your
current actions
are basically an effort to stay in power
and what's your response to that
that's preposterous you know i when i
was a young soldier 18 years old
i held a fellow soldier who died in my
arms
a few years later my brother my older
brother died while
leading a rescue mission in entebbia
uganda to release israeli hostages
i've seen comrades fall i've seen my
brother fall
and i think anybody who knows me knows
that i've never ever
subordinated security concerns the life
of our soldiers the life of our citizens
for political interest that's just
hogwash i'll do
what i have to do to protect the lives
of israeli citizens
and to restore peace i've made peace
with four arab countries
i'm glad that we have a restoration of
some
considerable calm within israel that's
my goal to restore
peace and quiet and to assure
tranquility
and reconciliation for all but this is a
persistent criticism mr prime minister
why do you think it persists
it persists because i've been reelected
five times it persists because
i beat every other candidate in public
polls and in direct election
simulations apparently the people of
israel the majority don't agree
with this false criticism and this
cynicism they know
that i'm standing there for israel and
i'm doing everything i can
for the safety and prosperity of the
israeli people by the way
all of israel citizens jews and arabs
alike all right mr prime minister
we're out of time this is not idle
speculation
the associated press reports that quote
just over a week ago the longtime
israeli leader's political career
seemed all but over he had failed to
form a coalition government
following an indecisive parliamentary
election
and his political rivals were on the
cusp of pushing him out of office
now as israel and gaza's hamas rulers
wage their fourth war in just over a
decade
fortunes have changed dramatically his
rivals prospects have crumbled
netanyahu is back in his comfortable
role as mr security
and the country could soon be headed for
yet another election campaign
that would guarantee him at least
several more
months in office rightly this is making
many people
ask was this another one of these
disgusting cynical moves that we've come
to expect from benjamin netanyahu we saw
this before
during the lead-up to an election in
israel and
exactly as i suggested i suspected on
monday
more people are now asking this exact
same question and
there's every indication that this is
exactly what is going
on will it work i wish i could say no
but sadly it might and of course the
longer netanyahu remains in power as
well as the longer hamas
remains in power the prospects of a real
peace deal are essentially
zero as i outlined earlier this week
this story um
is one i didn't pay much attention to at
the beginning because as i heard about
it i thought this has to be a joke
there's no way
republicans are this stupid but
unfortunately any time your instinct is
republicans couldn't possibly be this
stupid
take a step back and investigate because
republicans really could be this stupid
republicans are blaming joe biden's
administration
for a shortage of some sauces at the
chicken
chain chick-fil-a often affiliated with
homophobic right-wing ideology
i thought it was a joke but it's real
chick-fil-a announced that it was going
to limit how much sauce it would give
customers because of an industry-wide
supply chain issue so customers will
only get one
cup of sauce per item now i've never
been to a chick-fil-a
but a cup of sauce seems like a lot i've
never needed a cup of mayonnaise
for a meal i've never needed a cup of
ketchup or a cup of mustard for any meal
i've ever had
let's put that aside for a second
radical trumpian congresswoman lauren
bobert tweeted in response to the sauce
shortage quote is there no limit to how
awful bidens america can get
ted cruz tweeted joe biden is destroying
america
about the sauce shortage oklahoma
republican governor
kevin's tit uh his reelection campaign
now claims that quote joe biden's
radical liberal policies
are to blame for the sauce shortage at
chick-fil-a
his campaign published a whole thing
saying chick-fil-a
a gas sauce a chick-fil-a sauce shortage
gas shortage you want to know why
because of joe biden's radical liberal
policies now of course gas stations
had the shortage because of what
happened to a pipeline not because of
joe biden
gas prices are up and they have been
during the end of trump's term
because of increased demand as we come
out of the pandemic
and now supposedly chick-fil-a has a
sauce shortage
also because of joe biden and it seems
like a joke
but it is really not now kevin's tit
also said groceries are costing more
that's true
but that started before biden and it
doesn't have anything to do with joe
biden
now i tried in order to do this story
justice to find out exactly
how they believe biden caused a sauce
shortage
i couldn't find it my guess is it's
something about
biden didn't fix something related to
supply chains
or biden didn't open fast enough
something which would have
fixed supply chains i don't know it
doesn't make much sense but my guess is
that it would be something like that
that entire thanks obama thing from the
obama era where people would pretend to
blame obama for the silliest thing
i stubbed my toe my toe i got a paper
cut thanks obama
republicans today are making it a
reality with joe biden and chick-fil-a
now someone please explain to me why do
you need so many sauces at chick-fil-a
is the food not good and you need to
mask it with
endless cups of sauce you just need
massive dumps of multiple sauces
i've never been to a chick-fil-a i don't
understand why the sauce controversy is
such a controversy
but maybe someone can explain it to me
remember that monday memorial day
we're getting very close now my friends
monday memorial day we're doing a
one-day membership special
this is such an outrageous discount off
of membership that i can't even tell you
what it is now
but if you want to be notified on
memorial day it's very easy
you go to davidpakman.com you sign up
for my newsletter
and on monday memorial day you will get
a perfect email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great discount
we have a great program for you today
looking forward to hearing from some of
you
answering some of your questions and
much more coming up stay with us
find me on twitter at dpakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
we are going to hear from some of you
today
we are going to uh speak to people via
the david pakman show
discord which is it's the hot new thing
to quote the former guy you can find it
at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to
billy from california billy from
california you're on the air
david yes
listen the new york state attorney
general has announced that they're going
to start investigating
the trump organization not just a civil
capacity but in a criminal
that's right we covered it so there's
basically two things going on
the psy vance investigation was criminal
all along the leticia james
investigation
was civil it is now criminal you are 100
correct my friend sure and my question
is
when are you going to start pandering to
your audience a little bit
and dispel with this fiction that donald
trump is never going to get arrested and
that the united states doesn't arrest
presidents
i i still believe that i mean listen i
don't pander
one way or the other what i say on this
program is what i believe
i you know they're investigating the
trump organization
um criminally i think that if it reaches
trump it will be civil and i think if it
if
the criminal charges would be against
people other than trump and even if
trump is charged
i think there's no perp walk i think
there's no jail time
david do you think people listen to ben
shapiro because they think his takes are
interesting
they only listen to him because he tells
them what they want to hear you gotta
patronize us a little bit
tell us exactly how the perp walks gonna
go down
right exactly the jumpsuit sell
the view i want to hear it all but then
what happens is
when it never happens when it never
happens then people call in and say
david why were you saying trump was
going to get arrested and i'd have to be
like you know
i never really believed it i did it for
billy in california
that's fine that's fine then i look
stupid then i look even stupider than i
normally look
well it's a hard bar to
anyways thanks david i appreciate your
honest takes actually
um and for not giving us any sense of
falsehood but
i am still hopeful that at some point
justice is going to be served yes
we all remain in a prison cell but i
would love to see
trump perp walked in handcuffs believe
me i would
love it i just would be lying if i told
you i think it's going to happen
i hear you yeah all right my friend
billy from california
very important topic i appreciate it
let's go next to stevie
from asheville north carolina stevie you
are on the air
david how are you doing today i'm doing
well thank you for asking
all right thank you glad to be on the
show um my question for you today
is uh what is your opinion of the cdc
lifting these mask regulations
so i think that it's the outdoor stuff i
am 110
on board with i don't even really think
masks were necessary outdoors
before vaccination and certainly with
vaccination i think that that's
beautiful
on indoor here here's the problem what
you're basically saying when you say
you don't need to wear a mask indoors is
you're saying
we're leaving it up to the honor system
and the concern is because when they say
the risk is to the unvaccinated so if
you're unvaccinated you should wear a
mouse to protect yourself
um you're basically saying to people who
already weren't wearing masks
you now can just by sort of like
pretending to be vaccinated not have to
wear one and
that's what seems like a concern to me
but
i think that they're trying to balance
uh that
with wanting to incentivize as many
people as possible to go and get
vaccinated so
for like grocery stores for example my
instinct is it probably still makes
sense to require masks for a little
while
longer but generally speaking
these vaccines are really effective and
i understand that
over the next two to three months masks
are going to go away
whether it should be today or in three
or six weeks there's maybe
a debate there right uh you don't think
this will cause
any sort of uptick in covid cases do you
oh i think it very well might among the
unvaccinated who are choosing not to
wear masks
okay i see you yeah yeah i i had an
issue with um
you know the honor system as you
mentioned i i feel
i feel people people were already not
wearing masks who didn't want to wear
masks
exactly all they have to say is oh well
now i'm just yeah i'm vaccinated so
there's
if it's a complete honor system it's
just what what issue did you have
well my issue i i have friends who work
at grocery stores at
you know hardware stores um and i it
just it seems like people
who weren't it's a fatigue issue david
it's
you know they've been trying to force
the mask rule for so long that
as a service worker you just start to
give up when you see day in
after day in of people coming in without
wearing their masks and now with this
decision from the cdc
yeah people are saying oh well we were
already having this
issue now it is people have free reign
to just say oh we're vaccinated it
it i think it's a mess but they're not
actually in the position of saying to
customers
are you vaccinated right i mean it's
just it's assumed that if you're not
wearing a mask you've decided you don't
need to because you're vaccinated i did
or are you saying some of them are in
positions of having to ask customers if
they're vaccinated
oh it's an honor system so it should be
assumed it should be assumed
i think yeah there were there's a degree
of concern
of people who you know are worried of
someone who is not vaccinated coming
into the store without of course
okay i think that's that's the concern
well i expect to see employees
at many chains and businesses continue
to wear the masks longer than the
customers that seems to be clear yeah
yeah no it's it's it's definitely it's
gonna take some adjusting you know my at
my place of business i
decided to not wear my mask i'm
vaccinated myself and i felt naked
like not wearing a shirt it was it's
very a very weird feeling
humans adapt to so many things and in 14
months of mass squaring for the people
that have been doing it
you don't just get unaccustomed to it in
a day there will be a
an off-ramp and i think there will be
some challenges with it
right of course i mean i was able to
adjust to the microchip
that was implanted in me of course so
that's easier because it's so small it's
easy to adjust
a joke by to way you know because of
what happens right now
that is a complete joke please don't
demonetize or cancel me or anything
all right listen i'm gonna go before you
say more things that get me in trouble
okay
i apologize today all right take care
love asheville great
place never been there but love it just
from what people have told me let's go
next to
dominic from texas dominic you're on the
air
hi david um i had two questions
uh the first one is what do you think is
going to happen to fox news once
rupert murdoch is gone i don't know you
know i read an interesting long form
piece about six months ago about how
he has multiple kids i don't remember
which ones but like one of them
is very involved with fox and one of
them wants nothing to do with it
but there's the idea that the one that's
involved might take it in a different
direction but i don't know i don't have
any prediction really i think it
might change i just don't know exactly
how
do you think that they're well i mean i
don't think it will take a
rocket scientist to figure out that
they're still probably going to be
spewing the regular bs but
do you think it will get worse or do you
think it will get better i think it may
just
evolve in terms of the feel of it i
don't know worse or better kind of will
depend on the political environment and
the
cultural environment around it but
you're already sort of seeing fox news
have to
figure out what space will they occupy
because
you know the fake scandals they've been
concocting about jill and joe biden
don't really love each other it's an
act and you know just kind of like weird
mask stuff weird vaccine stuff it's not
none of it's really catching that much
and so i think fox news is already kind
of in a period of self-examination to
figure out what will work
and maybe a change now remember rupert
murdoch's not really handling the
day-to-day anyway and so rupert murdoch
being
gone to use your term it's not clear to
me that it will
necessarily change anything because you
you have other people that are managing
the day-to-day
okay and then my second question is
i know that you've talked about you
don't think that trump is going to be
charged and i agree with you i don't
think he is either
but uh what do you think about matt
gates i think
that if you give me an even odds bet
just will he be charged or won't he
i'm taking the yes he will be charged um
but it's not like i feel super strong
about it i think it's like 60 40 that
gates gets charged
do you think that he would like lose his
position or anything
well there are rules in the house of
representatives about that and i believe
that if
i'd have to review it but if you're
charged with a felony
i think you are automatically off of
committees
but i don't know that you have to resign
on unless
you're pro you're proven guilty so i
don't know about that i'd have to
it would depend on what the charges are
i think
okay yeah thanks a lot all right my
pleasure great questions uh great to
hear from you
let's hear from a few other people let's
go to
oh i need to speak to joshua from
portugal i have questions
joshua from portugal you're on the air
hello matt it is an odd
pact david sorry it's an honor to speak
with you
it's pat matt pat and david everybody's
here
sorry sorry i was i just didn't think
i'd get called on
uh thank you for thank you for that
listen i have a question for you are you
in portugal
yes i live here okay i have been
following
the travel restrictions in portugal very
closely
i was considering going to the azores
what i'm trying to do what i'm trying to
understand is
it looks like you can go to the azores
with a negative test regardless of what
the rules are in mainland portugal is
that true or do i have to wait for the
mainland
to open i don't think i think
i haven't checked but i believe the
restrictions are loosening up but i
still think you do need a
a a negative test if you are yes you
still need a negative tips if you're
going to the azores islands because it's
an island it's more
isolated than the rest of portugal but i
would be allowed to go to the azores
you're saying
yeah beautiful on just on your say-so
i'm going to book a ticket right after
the show
i'm happy can i actually may i ask you a
quick question
please i'm here at your service i thank
you
um david i was wondering like i don't
know
like sorry is it like
do you see politically wise do you see
yourself
as a social democrat a democrat or a
socialist because
i would i am very curious on that social
democrats social democrats
yes which is the northern european
version of capitalism those are my views
well it's technically a more european
view of capitalism social democracy
european northern european okay yes sure
sorry it's just like because i live in
uh you as you i guess i live in europe
and
i i
i like get a lot of headaches when
people call me
um a communist from the states despite
the fact that
i'm not a communist right like do you
get that a lot as well from other people
that
i do you a communist i do i get
communist
i get socialist i get zionist
i get authoritarian fascists i get
all of these things i'm just a social
democrat that's all
i know i know but i it's just like it's
frustrating
when i hear it because it's just not
every american but a lot of americans
just don't seem to get
the difference between the groups you're
completely correct
it is frustrating and americans don't
seem to get it and part of why they
don't get it is they've been fed lies
from republicans about what it means to
be socialist
yeah but yes it's just the ice and it's
in it
and they act like and they always use
that insult to me like where you just
say they call say
socialist to me like yeah i don't i can
never understand why they call me that
and i understand in the states it's a
slur there to call someone a socialist
but
to me you'll just miss i don't i don't
like labels and all that but
the way but it does help but right to
you it's like
it's it's like saying oh you're a
keynesian and making it an insult rather
than just
a description of your economic beliefs
that's very true and again it gets me
frustrated a lot but i apprec
sorry i don't know how to but uh thank
you very much i hope i do hope you enjoy
your trip to the azores
uh david i've not been there but they
are very beautiful islands
i hope it happens and uh i so appreciate
the phone call it's been a perfect phone
call
thank you all right very good there's
joshua from portugal
listen if you're holding to talk to me
right now i'm begging you don't hang up
because we're taking a very quick break
it'll feel like almost nothing if you're
holding and then i'm going right back to
the discord lines momentarily
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
uh all right let's try way
from nashville tennessee way
you were on the air hey david can you
hear me
yes i can oh hey um
so i guess uh i don't know i'm kind of
seeing this
new uh mississippi abortion bill
being pushed to the supreme court or the
supreme court's willing to
examine it i haven't looked at it
yeah so it's it's a new uh wall
or bill from mississippi that has
something to do with
making adjustments or or limiting uh
roe v wade and i just don't see like
how that could i mean i see in a reality
sense that the the conservative majority
could change it but like
what actual common sense is sort of
backing that because we've had
roe v wade in place for what 50 years
now
yeah this is the the idea here is not
that any one
bill is necessarily going to be what in
creates alternative precedent to change
roe v wade
it's they just want to keep hammering
hammering hammering and as soon as they
can get
anything favorable from the supreme
court it will then become the model
in more states to clamp down on abortion
so i get it you you look at this one
bill and you rightly say
this makes no sense we have roe v wade
but that's the whole point
keep sending things up to the supreme
court and try to
slowly erode abortion rights now i have
to ask you
there's a hissing a clapping and horn
honking in the background
where are you right now describe it to
us
i'm really sorry i'm at work right now
i'm walking like in the back of the
warehouse
i can't stay away from that stuff is
there a forklift is there a forklift
going by you right now
um no but there's these big fans on the
roof that
are spinning and i'm real sorry about
that that's okay no i
you were well intentioned it's a great
question and the strategy is
keep hammering away and wait until you
can get something favorable from the
supreme court
and they just may because we have one of
the most right-wing supreme courts in a
long time
okay cool uh also one more question so
like
uh just watching like the sort of trash
propaganda and just bad
faith from like tarko carlson and a lot
of other fox news
uh posts and whatnot like you think it's
worth debating
like like a tucker carlson like is that
gonna
would that even be worth time is it
worth it for who to debate tucker
carlson is the question
yeah i guess i guess that's that depends
but it's like i don't know like
you maybe i mean sure maybe i mean
you like honest show you know here's the
thing about all these questions
it's like what's the format what's the
topic
what's the point who's the audience
where does it air there's no one
question
the one answer to these different
questions i do think it's worth refuting
bad ideas and in that sense
it's worth refuting tucker carlson
all right well uh thanks for taking my
call david my pleasure
all right we'll let you get back to the
warehouse there just a lot going on
there really a lot happening but it's
great to hear from so many different
people
why don't we go next to why don't we try
ruth from canada ruth you were on the
air
hi david hi where in canada are you
calling from
alberta oh beautiful that's a very
conservative area isn't it
yes unfortunately what's uh what's going
on yeah
so i have two questions um a few years
ago i think you
you hosted or you you produced a bunch
of
youtube clips about discussing logical
fallacies right
and things like that wondering if you
would do an
updated version of that well you know
i don't know if we're going to update
that specifically
but we are now working uh this is a
exclusive to ruth from canada
announcement
um we are now looking at revitalizing
our sort of long-form
deep dives and really competing head-on
with the trash from prageru and their
bogus right-wing explainers
so this is currently in development and
so i don't know if we're going to redo
the critical thinking series
but we're going to do all sorts of new
explainers
and um i think that there will be a lot
of things
to look forward to as far as that goes
for it looking forward to it um my
second question is
uh mcconnell's just confirmed and
no surprise to anyone that he wouldn't
support an independent
investigation of the january 6th uh riot
yeah and the term independent i mean
it's really what we're talking about is
bipartisan right
democracy it's not so much independent
as bipartisan but yeah mitch mcconnell
said he's not going to support it
what do you think the likely what do you
think the likelihood is that the
investigation will be able to move
forward i actually think it will
partially because it's the house that
would be doing it and mitch mcconnell is
in the senate i know he still
wields power of course but there are
also at least 20 and maybe as many as 50
republicans who want to see it happen
so um i think that it i do believe it
will happen
awesome okay well love your show thanks
so much thanks ruth great to hear from
you
sorry you're in such a right-wing haven
in uh
in canada there i've heard a lot of
things about alberta it can get pretty
brutal from what i've read
uh okay we're speaking to people via
discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place to find it let's go
next to sam from new york city you're on
the air
hey thanks so much for taking my call i
just wanted to ask you know i'm
all about abolishing the filibuster i'm
all about putting pressure on you know
joe manchin
and the like i think that is critical if
we want to get progressive agenda passed
especially some of these
voting rights bills but you know west
virginia i think it's like the second
trumpiest state in terms of just like
you know 2020
vote share and so my concern is that
even though i don't agree with the more
moderate democrats i think
being too willing to criticize and oust
them from the party could just result in
a future where
to get 50 votes in the senate we're
looking at
36 47 48 as we sort of miss
any chance of having democratic senators
in
purple or reddish states goodbye you
know if i totally agree with you
i've been making this point for years
and i know that there are people who
will get mad at this example
but here's the reality if you primary
joe manchin with bernie sanders and
democrats in west virginia pick bernie
over joe manchin
i don't see how the hell bernie then
wins the general senate election
in west virginia now maybe at some point
that specific example won't be a good
one
but i completely agree with you in
principle which is sometimes when
when democrats want to replace a
centrist democrat with a
further left democrat the most likely
scenario would be that it's just a
republican who wins and that's worse
no exactly i completely agree and i
guess i also worry in terms of getting
rid of the filibuster though i support
it if you do that in isolation
that's where it really concerns me
because in isolation
you eliminate the filibuster but we're
in a system what is it republicans got
40 million or democrats got 40 million
more votes
uh in the most recent senate elections
than uh republicans yet the senate still
split when there's such a structural
disadvantage for democrats
i think creating a more majoritarian
system
the senate when the senate is so biased
towards republicans could be a recipe
for disaster yeah republicans
seem to support any real policy anyway i
completely agree with you and
uh the other important thing to remember
is
there are you know when we talk about
the obstacles to getting
x done rarely is there one blanket
explanation for why
x won't get done there's usually
different explanations for different
things
when you have a bill that joe biden
wants but two democratic senators don't
want
versus a bill that joe biden uh wants
but every senator wants but every
democratic senator wants but it requires
60 instead of 50
meaning it's now on republicans every
one of these scenarios is a different
scenario and there's not one solution
and the solution of
just primary every centrist democrat and
then it'll solve all your problems i
don't think it's a realistic solution i
think it will
maybe solve some and create new problems
as well
totally would you mind if i asked one
last question go ahead by the way is
this sam cedar or a different sam from
new york city
oh different different okay got it okay
i'm calling actually got it
um yeah what i was going to say is um i
was just wondering your take
one thing that really frustrates me is
how like american-centric
americans world views and political
views tend to be and just that
all of our focus is always on domestic
politics when there are
only like huge british elections just
earlier this week and
there are crises happening across the
globe and i understand that a lot
is happening in the us and it's good to
pay attention but what do you think
is our responsibility as americans who
have the privilege to
uh have access to global news to stay up
to date on
not only international politics but the
domestic politics of other countries
yeah i mean um i think that i would
prioritize
if you if you find someone who pays no
attention to what's going on outside the
u.s
i would suggest first start paying
attention to what's going on
internationally that would be a higher
priority than
knowing the internal politics of other
countries if you if you say we'll pick
one to start with
um i think it's very easy when you live
in a country like the united states that
dictates so much of global culture and
global technology and so many different
things
just to basically be in an island and
only pay attention
to what happens in the u.s i think it
leads to very narrow world views
um and i think it leads to people who
it leads to that wing of the republican
party where we said hey
earlier this week europe announced it
would open to vaccinated people
and i said you know i don't think this
will be much of an incentive to the
anti-vaccine republicans because
they already think europe is just about
sissies and communists
there's a whole culture of people who
proactively are hostile
to the idea of what happens in other
countries mattering and you have to
change the culture around that
totally i think when you consider just
how crucial the role of our allies is
um and you look at the fact that right
germany is going to have a new
chancellor
at the end of the year france has
elections next summer
a lot of things are going to change even
a lot of things that could impact
joe biden's ability to get his foreign
policy agenda done yeah we pay
very little attention but i agree with
you about the prioritization
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it
thank you so much take care all right
you too of really strong calls today i
have to tell you a lot of very
interesting topics
why don't we go next to um
let's just try somewhere else let's go
to alfie in london
now is that london uk
yeah yeah london uk well welcome you're
on the air
hey thanks for picking me um i just
thought would it be okay if i just use
you as
a way to settle a sort of long time
dispute
i can try sure i can try um
so would you say a flamingo is a pink
or would you say peach is probably a
better way to describe it
you know i think that flamingos i would
describe them as
salmon colored oh no
yeah i don't know oh no that's just made
it worse okay
i mean i think it's more uh i you know i
think it actually depends
on it depends now i know that there's
people who will say the flamingo
is white but it takes on the color of of
what it eats
we're dealing with what color does it
end up right i think that's really the
question that you're asking
um i think it's regionally different to
be perfectly honest i think in some
cases it's more pink in some cases more
peach
okay yeah okay oh that doesn't help
david i'm sorry
um all right you'll vote in third party
right now by choosing salmon i hope you
know that
i'm sorry i'm doing what so oh by
choosing salmon i'm third party yes
listen how are things in london you guys
are doing so well with cases and deaths
being so low
um yeah i think it may be the calm
before the storm
oh everyone's talking about the indian
variant at the moment
the indian variant is well handled by
the vaccines from everything i've read
yeah yeah but it's just sort of the talk
of the town at the moment i see
um but yeah as of monday we're able to
eat indoors um
groups of up to six people yep um yeah
it's looking good
what is your you know one of the things
i love about the uk in general is all of
the different pubs with different names
that are often very similar but just
slightly different like the you know
the lamb's head and the you know all
these different things what is the name
of your favorite pub
um oh this thing
do you mean do you mean my favorite name
of a pub or the name of my favorite pub
i will accept either but ideally one
that you like going to
um there is a really nice place in
london called
the uh the green pea love it
yeah and it's really nice um yeah i'm
not sure how they're doing at the moment
because their owner
they also own and operate by this one
guy who passed away
uh about a year back i'm sorry to hear
that
no it's yeah but it was a really nice
place local to us and so we went to
there all the time
and they do uh they do sunday roast and
everything yeah
yeah yeah you gotta love that sunday
roast you know
yeah i'm not the biggest fan me neither
is a bit of um
sacrilegious yeah no i don't like it
well you just said you love it all right
my friend no i'm just kidding around
i do actually like it last time i was
there i went to a great sunday roast uh
they had a vegan option a vegetarian
option
a meat eaters option they had a pasta as
you say they had everything oh nice
all right thank you for the call i
really appreciate it yep thanks for
doing take michael thank you all right
perfect perfect call let's see
where else we can go why not um
oh i don't know what about maybe steve
from illinois
steve from illinois yes you're on the
air
can you hear me all right i can
uh i was just wondering were you
thinking of the recent
uh story uh about biden uh opening up
the pipe the russian pipeline for
germany
oh i i haven't even been following it
did he say he wants to do that
uh reports are saying that he's leaning
towards uh
lifting the restrictions or the
sanctions on it to open it back up
i did not see that i'll have to i wish i
could say i don't i don't know enough
about it i'm gonna have to check on that
oh good what's your opinion oh okay go
ahead yeah
oh sorry uh i was i just i just find it
i
i don't know i find it kind of odd i
don't know much information on it it
seems
kind of like an odd move i moved to me i
don't know
i'm not saying there's anything
nefarious it just seems like a weird
move to me i'll i'll research it and
follow up
um the only other kind of question i had
is
um again i listen to your show i'm more
like
right leaning but i was like listen to
your show because i feel like you're
very intelligent and kind of know what
you're talking about
um i understand you're you and your fans
hatred of fox but i'm just wondering
i mean if you watch cnn or snc they
like say a lot of nonsense as well
so is it like they understand there's
nonsense on both sides but they just
don't like the more the nonsense on fox
news or
do they fall in the line and not realize
that like
a lot of major cable news networks are
spewing a lot of nonsense
well as far as my audience is concerned
you'd have to ask them my view is that
certainly msnbc and cnn have corporate
bias and they have advertiser bias and
they have a lot of the types of bias
that that exist
but they are not promoting you know just
out and out
conspiracy stuff like having guest after
guest for two months making completely
bogus claims about the election or
pushing hydroxychloroquine for months
even when uh you know a
randomized controlled trial say it
doesn't work on coronavirus
it's just a different it's a different
caliber altogether but i think that
there's many criticisms of cnn and msnbc
they're just different than that of fox
oh okay okay
yeah that's uh totally understandable i
mean uh i
i mean i see i guess different levels of
conspiracy slash like
stuff on the on those other shows i
guess just from my side
on things but like what's a conspiracy
from cnn
try it i like sorry i don't have one on
top of my head i know like watching it i
mean
the i'm not gonna like i know sciences
but i mean they were going on a hole
when the cdc was talking about lifting
the mass mandates i know a bunch of
i mean i watched george talk about how
she's wearing two masks when she
uh runs outside on there to wear masks
when you're vaccinated even though the
cdc was coming out and saying you don't
need to wear that so it just seems like
they're going anti-science from what the
cdc's going into okay yeah she's on
msnbc i think i mean i i would be
interested in seeing that if that's what
she said
then that would be not in line with the
science but i think it's different than
saying like you know
take hydroxychloroquine i mean cnn had
uh governor cuomo on praising him and
then there's all these reports about the
nursing homes and everything like that
not questioning him on anything on that
okay i don't know the timing of that you
know we covered the nursing home scandal
when i learned of it i'm not saying i'm
not saying i'm not saying you i'm not
yeah no i got it
i'm not saying to you yeah like i said i
mean listen there's fair criticisms of
msnbc and cnn and the two you just
pointed out if you're describing them
accurately and the timing is as you
describe
i would be on board with you on those
criticisms
okay no i was just trying to see what
you thought of if you thought there was
any criticisms on the other side i know
you kind of focus on fox but
yeah kind of seeing if you saw any
criticisms on the other side
the two the two that you're mentioning
if they are as you describe i probably
would agree with you
i appreciate your time david thank you
all right thank you so much see
reasonable caller we're getting along
with a right winger it's all great
all right everybody thank you for
calling in i cannot get to any more
calls
today but i will take more calls soon
thank you
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
okay let's jump into audience questions
for the week first question is
david we know joe biden is polling quite
well from a standpoint of approval
but why isn't kamala harris nearly as
popular as joe biden so i didn't even
know about this i looked into it and
it's true
kamala harris's approval rating is quite
a bit lower uh economist yougov poll has
about 51
approval for joe biden only 41 approval
for kamala harris
lower certainly outside of the margin of
error um
in a more recent poll um
harris was at 26 very favorable with joe
biden 33 at very favorable there is a
gap it's not a massive gap
and given that i don't find it hugely
surprising that kamala harris is not
polling as well as joe biden for a few
different reasons
first of all she was never as popular as
joe biden during the primaries there was
a period there
i think when she had that bomb drop
moment about biden being racist or
something during a debate
where she gained a little bit and then
she very quickly
within a couple of weeks lost that and
she was never super popular
so unless there's some reason why she
would now be very popular
it's not surprising to me that she's not
doing super well
uh as far as approval the second piece
of it is
joe biden often talks about the biden
harris administration
and kamala harris is often there at
different things but
she's not been particularly present
as a major player in a lot of the things
that
are what makes joe biden popular today
i'm not saying she wasn't a major player
i'm saying it just hasn't been
apparent from much of the way that the
stories have been covered covet stimulus
for example it really
was framed as this is biden negotiating
and then democrats in the house and
senate getting it done and harris is
there you know in the room as has often
been said
but she's not sufficiently connected to
it and then
lastly there is a kind of personality
aspect which is as the vice president
she hasn't taken the spotlight uh now
some may say well she's not been allowed
to that may be i'm not saying
that she's chosen not to i'm saying she
hasn't been in the spotlight and that
means that the discourse
is sort of happening around her more
than being shaped by
her actions herself now there's one last
thing on and it's sort of a
propagandistic thing we've talked about
how
the republican party and right-wing
media
and others have concocted the
immigration
crisis the crisis at the border now the
truth
is things aren't much different at the
border than they were under donald trump
uh they've gotten significantly better
actually in the last six weeks which
we've reported on but
the the narrative has been it's a border
crisis
and it worked in that back in june only
28
of the country thought there was a
crisis at the border last month
48 of the country believed there was a
crisis at the border so the propaganda
has worked how does this relate to
kamala
it relates to kamala harris because she
was
designated as the person who was going
to
handle the situation at the border now
if you believe it's a crisis and you
believe what fox news says that
nothing's been done
and you remember that it was assigned to
kamala harris
you probably don't have a particularly
high view
of favorable view of kamala harris so i
think that the negativity around that
probably
is not is not helping her either that's
my sense
never really popular to begin with not
in the spotlight for
joe biden's successes and i don't want
to say thrown under the bus
but tied to a
fabricated so-called crisis at the
border
because it was assigned to her portfolio
and the right-wing media narrative is
just that the crisis continues
regardless of what the truth is there
send me your thoughts if you have a
different view
as to why kamala's approval is lower
than than biden's and last thing
i think generally the vice president has
a lower approval than the president
i think it was the case with mike pence
and donald trump for most of his
presidency correct me if i'm wrong i'm
going from memory
um it doesn't strike me as shocking for
that reason either
hey david we see more and more sexual
assault allegations and sexual
harassment allegations against
candidates and it seems to matter less
than ever
do voters even care about sexual
harassment
anymore i think that this is a an
interesting question
for a couple of different reasons it
does seem as though
lately candidates and other prominent
people
get hit with allegations of sexual
harassment or sexual assault
they don't drop out or resign or go into
therapy or whatever you know there's
different ways that it's sometimes
handled
and they still sort of do okay i mean
donald trump is example number one
accused by
you know 16 to 48 different women at
different points in time
and didn't drop out and was elected
president period
there was that special election in
alabama where republican roy moore who
was accused of harassing underage women
lost by only a point and a half in 2017.
now
a republican losing by 1.5 in alabama
is a big deal because it's such a red
state but
it didn't completely knock him out of
the running if a couple things went a
little differently he still would have
won
andrew cuomo he has been accused of
all sorts of improper touching and
verbal comments by multiple women
he has said at least for now he's not
going to resign even if he's not cleared
by the attorney general report
he's made public appearances with other
legislative leaders
some of whom called for him to resign
but
about half of new yorkers don't think he
should resign that includes 61 percent
of democrats
it's still currently under the
investigation phase but we've seen
people resign during investigations
before and it's not clear it's having a
major impact some of the coveted
mishandling
is with the nursing home scandal we
talked about previously but
he's just still kicking around matt
gates now matt gates
allegedly paid for sex from underage
women for whom he paid
to go from one state to another which
legally counts as sex trafficking
not facing too many calls to resign
the republican caucus is basically
behind him
um it's not clear whether it's going to
affect him
unless he's actually charged and even
then we're going to wait and see
during the brett kavanaugh confirmation
hearings to the supreme court
he maintained very high republican
support
uh after um christine blasey blasey ford
testified um brett kavanaugh's approval
from
republicans went up even if i recall
correctly so
there's a couple different things going
on here we sort of knew
a lot of people didn't really care uh
but increasingly it seems as though
it's not playing a role in politics
where there are more people taking the
approach of it depends who you talk to
but
a lot of democrats taking the approach
of if republicans aren't going to hold
them accountable
why are we going to go crazy the al
franken situation comes to mind where
compared to the things republicans have
been accused of
and just stuck it out al franken's
resignation is now seen as premature by
many
given what he was accused of an
untasteful joke for tasteless joke no
no doubt about it but comparatively
you've seen a lot of democrats say hey
let's not go crazy
because they're not doing anything about
these allegations on their side i think
republican voters genuinely don't care
they have taken a sort of greater good
mentality of
yeah even if we're evangelical
christians we'll still elect the guy
with the multiple wives and the cheating
and the divorce and the mistresses and
whatever
because democrats are just worse in
general and they support abortion and
whatever
so they justify it that way so i think
that while individuals
in their lives care about sexual
harassment and sexual assault
i think politically it is less of a
successful or effective
hatchet to end someone's career and
that's a result
both of some aspects from the right and
some aspects from the left although the
left has been far more consistent
when it came to al franken anthony
weiner and just abandoning the accused
people
i think some sort of real politic type
pragmatic perspective lately
is making even some on the left uh
reconsider whether we should just leave
the sexual harassment to
that's the personal life of the
individual and at least
claim that it has nothing to do with
their
actions as an elected official hey david
does it
matter that most trumpists still don't
accept that donald trump lost
this is a really good question there's
two answers does it matter electorally
no
i mean i know we hear about an audit
looking for bamboo fibers in arizona
and something's happening in michigan
and north carolina you know whatever
going to have zero electoral impact
other than
continuing to push republicans to try to
suppress even more of the vote in 2022
and certainly in 2024
for me the fact that most republicans
still don't believe trump lost
is disturbing is because of what it
represents about the united states of
america
i don't believe that you can have
long-term
stability of institutions of government
of a society of a culture
when you don't even have agreement as to
what are facts
again i didn't say what the facts are
there is not even agreement now as to
what constitutes a fact
a statement of fact an empirical
statement and as i've said before
we can disagree when it comes to our
opinions about things
but when one is presented with facts
about what took place
and you respond with my opinion is
different you were
outside of the world of empiricism you
were outside of the world of fact and
rationality and thinking
how does a country remain stable when
you have so much of one party that
believes
the person who won didn't really win he
won by millions of votes
uh other than some typical anecdotal but
statistically insignificant
irregularities this was not a close
election
and then on the basis of that false
belief they support
a literal insurrection uh the vaccines
work
covet is real biden one these are facts
and they don't believe them
they don't understand that they are
facts it is not subject to opinion
and so that the election is not accepted
as legitimate
is really a sign of a mass
radicalization
it's a mass delusion it's a tribal
psychosis
as i've referred to it before but they
believe that
even their ability to comment on this is
being silenced by their political
enemies as they see them when it's not
they're just wrong they just don't have
the facts on their hands and if they
start winning elections
through more voter suppression which is
what they plan to do
and they ramp up this dehumanizing
rhetoric
against their political enemies history
points in bad directions when that
happens
so i worry we will see even more overt
political violence than we're already
seeing
we can look at all sorts of other uh
injured or imperfect democracies around
the world
and you start seeing really ugly things
happen in and around
elections and so i think that there is
uh it's easy to laugh off and say stupid
trump is who just can't accept the facts
yeah that's true but this is a much
bigger issue and think back to when
trump was asked in 2016
if the results say you lost
will you accept that you lost and he
said i'm gonna wait and see
i'll keep you in suspense that was a
dangerous vile statement
that didn't get nearly the blowback at
the time everybody even republicans then
should have said
that has to be rejected period and
republicans voted the guy in they did
the opposite
which in essence endorses that type of
thinking
that leads and points towards tyranny so
on a day-to-day level listen i don't
want an accountant who thinks trump won
i don't want a doctor who thinks trump
won i don't
work with or hire people who have such
delusional beliefs
that's something i do at a personal
level but there is a bigger issue here
and the degree of radicalization and
separation from reality that it points
to
if we look historically it does not bode
well for the united states that's where
i would i would leave it
and i'm curious to hear from you make
sure to get yourself
a membership on my website today at
joinpackman.com
and thus you will get instant access to
today's bonus show
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman